meeting on wednesday 13th of october we
are sitting under the licensing act 20
20 20
sorry 2003 to hear an application made
under the act my name is councillor
stilts and i have been appointed
chairman for the meeting before we start
the applicant hasn't arrived so i'm just
going to check with our legal
representative that it's okay to carry
on
yes it's it's fine chair thank you
chairman's notes before we commence the
business of the meeting there are a few
housekeeping issues to run through
members the setup for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate for covid
therefore can i ask all present to work
under the prototrolls agreed at council
on 2nd of september 2020
in the interest of members and officer
safety we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded
members and officers during
each item please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak and then i
will invite you appropriate time
when invited to speak
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished please
reference a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers and
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chambers
and advise that the exit advise at the
fire exit is the door behind this top
table
now may i wish all persons present this
meeting to introduce themselves i will
start with the councillors
council maddy thompson
councillor richard siddall chairman of
licensing
thank you nero we'll start with the
offices that are present
daniel winter licensing officer at
champs city council and district
malden district council thank you thank
you
callum roberts licensing apprentice for
chancellor city council thank you
emma holmes legal specialist molten
district council thank you
and we have an objector to this
application
if you'd like to introduce yourself
i'm julia clark i was clinical you just
just need to know who you are that's all
for this you don't
i don't need you to read the timer yeah
i don't need you to read any of your
letter out yet no no no
no what's it say at the bottom
all i need is your name that's that's
all i need for this okay okay if you'd
like to send your michael lovely thank
you
item four on the agenda oh item three on
your gender is apologies to for absence
as of the 12th of
october we have no apologies for absence
item four is declaration of interest to
disclose the existence of nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
peculiar interests or non-pecuniary
interests related to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
six to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded that they are
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting do i
have any declarations of interest
thank you
item five on the agenda
is the application for a new premises
license for chutney house
116 high street moulder
we move to item 5 on the agenda found on
pages 5 to 60.
i refer
everyone present at the to the aid
memoir found on page two of the agenda
pack which details the procedure which
we will follow for the meeting below
please could i ask firstly that everyone
has read the officer's repo and the
appendi submitted with the
um
okay lovely
yeah we'll come to that later yeah which
was circulated prior to this meeting
should anyone have any late
documentation in support of a
presentation or the application this may
only be interest with consent of all
parties
so do we have anything else
members
and those present
i now call on mr winter to provide a
brief outline of the application mr
winters
good morning members and all others
present um i hope you can hear me
clearly
the purpose of this hearing is to
consider an application for a new
premises license under section 17 of the
licensing act 2003
having regard to representations
received and the requirement to promote
the full licensing objectives which are
listed below
we recommend that licensing subcommittee
determines the application for a
premises license taken into
consideration the options are available
as detailed in 4.1 below
chutney house is a restaurant for fine
dining and private parties it is located
on malden high street surrounded by
other commercial properties as well as
residential properties above and near to
the premises in question
the completed application was received
on the 18th of august 2021 for the
following licensing activities which are
detailed below
as part of the licensing process a
complete
copy of the application was sent out to
responsible authorities for consultation
the application has been
before we carry on can i ask members and
officers if you're happy for the
applicant to be present as she has
arrived late
i am in principle i've got some legal
advice
okay legal advice the applicant has
arrived late
how would
um
we will we have to remain impartial um
and we
it has to be a fair hearing
thank you chairman i'd i'd like to put
forward a recommendation that we
uh continue with the hearing with the
applicant here um and that mr winter
just
does a quick recap as to where we've got
to for the benefit of the applicant okay
everybody's in agreement so
welcome miss bagan
and
mr winters would you like to start again
no problem
good morning
the purpose of this hearing is to
consider an application for a new
premises license under section 17 of the
licensing act 2003 have regard to
representations received and the
requirement to promote full licensing
objectives as listed below
we recommend that the licensing
subcommittee determines the application
for a premises license taking into
consideration the options that are
available as detailed in 4.1 below
chutney house is a restaurant for fine
dining and private parties which is
located on malden high street surrounded
by other commercial properties as well
as residential properties above and near
to the premises in question
the complete application was received on
the 18th of august 2021 for the
following licensing activities which are
detailed below
as part of the licensing process a
complete copy of the application was
sent out to responsible authorities for
consultation
the application has been properly made
in accordance with the license in our
2003 and all procedures correctly
followed
the proposed designated premises
supervisor is also the applicant who has
obtained a personal license from london
borough of newham in order to authorize
the sales of alcohol on a licensed
premises
the completed application and consent
form are attached as appendix a
the application was correctly advertised
in a locally circulated newspaper within
the time scale allocated under
legislation and on malden council's
website
members are also asked to note that as
this report is published publicly
personal details have been redacted from
others from some documents however the
licensing authority and the applicant
have received complete copies of all the
documents
during the course of the consultation
period representation was received from
15 members of the public covering all
four grounds of the licensing objectives
as listed in section 1.1
copies of the representations received
are attached to this report as appendix
b
a plan indicating the location of the
premises is attached as appendix c
however there is an additional
plan that
are displayed on the
board which might help as to determine
the location
during the course of the consultation
the applicant agreed to conditions
requested by essex police which are
attached as appendix d and also with the
environmental services as appendix e
to conclude
members are advised that they have the
following options when determining the
application they can grant the
application on the terms and conditions
applied for
they can grant the application on the
terms and conditions apply for modified
to such extent as considered appropriate
to promote the four licensing objectives
or they can refuse the application in a
whole or in part
members are reminded the applicant and
or any person making representation in
relation to this matter may appear
appeal the decision of the council to
the magistrate's court
members that concludes my report thank
you thank you mr winters i now call upon
the applicant miss
fagin
um if you would like to make a
statement you turn your microphone on
please
morning everybody thank you for your
patience and apologies for the delay
this morning
um my representative couldn't make it
today because it was a positive
of course of course can him better now
right just an opening
statement chutney house is an authentic
indian restaurant offering a high
quality dining experience to our
customers on the premises at high street
modern an applicant had
made a supply of alcohol of the promises
between the hours of 11am to 11 pm
amended time based upon representative
representation received
chutney house and the proposed license
holders are a responsible individual
keen to ip fpas the concern of local
residents and complaints
compliance we understand there are a
number of concerns regarding several
areas of chutney health smell a number
of representatives prefer to smell
created by the
premises itself with concern focused
upon the smell and odour caused by the
cooking
it should be noted that all commercial
extract system are in a place of
promises these concerns also do not
relate to the premises license that has
been applied for
as that is the sale of alcohol
it should also be noted that no concern
has been raised by environmental health
related to the applicant with regards
smell
noise in light of the representation
made regarding noise we have agreed to
change the operating how operating how
hours of the premises
closing room five early and stopping all
amusing and alcohol cell at 11 pm
it should also be noted that no concern
has been raised by environmental health
relating to this applicant with the
regards noise drunk and disorder
behavior as a
responsible company we fully comply with
the current licensing law
recognize that it's an offence under the
lies in the act 2003 to i can knowingly
severe serve alcohol to a drunken person
or to obtain alcohol for a drunken
person
we aim to offer a high quality dining
experience and do not desire to create
an environmental
encounter drunk and disorder behavior
behavior
it should also be noted that no
consensus has been raised by the police
or the local licensed authority relating
to this applicant application
with regards drunk and disorder or
anti-social behavior
we
feel that chutney house adds a lot of
value to the local community through its
provision of a high quality fine dining
experience
and feel that the optical
ability to dine and purchase alcohol to
eat with a table meal only adds to the
experience we feel that the suggestion
listed conditions are robust and failed
to ensure that licensing objectives are
up upheld too
thank you
and your representative chatty house
hasn't come
hasn't come
because he showed positive for the
council thank you
um so i now like to call on miss clark
an objector to make a statement
if you
if you would
look at what it says here at the bottom
what does it say
this
ability
i have disability yeah and i don't speak
very well it's fine it's better if i
read out that's fine
that's fine you're right
if you just bend your mic down a little
bit
just do it
just that's it
can you turn yours off please
okay
my name is julia clark
i was a clinical neuropsychologist
who retired exactly two years ago
without chance to see anybody
i'm now retired
i live in the
cons concert
conservation area on what's first and
there was a crossing out of numbers
unfortunately
any numbers
and i
who
owns the beautiful home right built in
sometime in 1800s called the go go go
get
gaggles
do you a yeah balls games
gables he owns the
total building
in
march 2014
so he owns both
upstairs and dances
number one
uh
light
light night
light
light knife
will cause
life or
wreck record
music sorry i can't
yeah it's fine
would you like us to read can we really
i would like to try that's fine
yeah too much yeah no that's fine
um it's about
cause
of life and
retro
recording music
either inside or outside the building
but it's
worry if it's outside the building if
it's very late at
night
suddenly it will affect people who need
to
work very
early in the morning
because i i see how many people have to
get up very early in the morning i i
don't say the numbers the people i
definitely live next next door to people
and i know what time they have to get
out some men have to get to three
o'clock in the morning to drive off
to
have
a dog to do
number two
public nuisance with cause of
we will with cause
vibrations
lighting and glitter in the area and you
saw i i
went to do
this
to remind me
where how close
the diff different areas are
the daycart is so close
about
five feet away it's so close
number three
elderly people are living in this area
so that they can walk easily for
food and general
goods on the high street and if you walk
through
here
it's very close it's lovely to be so
close to the
it's beautiful
but you've got to be very careful about
this
public
think safety
to people eg who require the use of
walking aids wheelchairs
and
mobile scooters
and
generally there are a lot of older
people in this area who live very close
it's it worries me because i walk
through as well
and sadly i i hate to say this to the
lady over there
but you're not looking after
the area
where
this one this area you all have this one
if you walk through here
you have to go up here to get because we
love coming to this place to eat food we
want to come
but we may be working with our old lady
or old man with us
to get up in into
into this place
it's quite steep it's the right place
right place i was saying
that
it was for you as well
you you it's accepted
it's made a perfect place to go into
it's good food beautiful
but it's
if it ever it's not quite clean it's
very bad for you and i can tell you if
you want to walk through
today
check
because it can cause a lot of accidents
so i suppose
i
i'm affected for other people because
they're elderly
and not quite so much the other things
that's all right that's that's lovely
thank you do you have any other um
witnesses that you would like to call
miss clark
there isn't any so i'll go and move on
um i will call on you to make a closing
statement so is there anything you want
to say to just round up
no
i i i'm quite
worried by how close
your little people inside the
office and decide where
where you have
the beautiful things inside why isn't
outside it's clean sad and why are you
not being careful of people outside the
only thing i will say miss clark is that
we are actually looking at licensing of
the alcohol
and not so much on
the outside of the premises and
discount
if if if i'm one of these people else
and
people who want to see problems
um if you'd like to turn your mic off i
will then go to uh miss bagan to make a
closing statement
yeah we will
face the state comes later well that's
what i've got in there
well we can ask questions questions
yeah
so
i'll let you make your closing statement
and then we'll ask some questions
um
before i make a closing statement um
i wanted to answer a few of the
residents questions if that's okay with
you guys
and regarding the concerning about the
cleaning i've actually spent my own
money invested in into the area
surrounding area where the alleyway is
to clear it out i've actually cut all
the bushes which is not inside the
premises of chutney house it's a
communal area but i still spent time and
money
get hired people and skips to cut the
bushes and get it cleared out if you
make a personal visit you can see it's
always clean and we do our very best
because if we use it as well well as the
neighbors do as well
um
regarding
the noise and the lights
um i did make an application for 10
occasions
and so it won't be
every day it would be like 10 occasions
of the music
and of everything else the whole year
and the closing statement
i would abit by
in the decision that is made by the
council um at respective honorary and
take it abroad and one request i have
which would be whatever the decision is
i need it before the 16th of
october because as you know i run a
business i need the license
to run the business and it would be
help from you guys okay thank you uh
members would you like to ask some
questions uh i would love to ask
uh mr speaker so you're saying that uh
you'll own
play
loud music on 10 occasions in a year is
that correct
that's a live music okay so you'll play
with the request okay so you'll play
recorded music recorded music all
i believe there is a certain hours i can
play until 11 o'clock in the p.m that
was agreed by the council so you you put
in a quest to play like music to that
particular time that's recorded music
sorry
you
are saying that you
are trying to create a high quality
dining experience
so
i'm not sure
why you want to play a film
at
12 30 at night
could you explain that please
that has been amended to 11 o'clock
not on my report
that's been amended to 11 o'clock and it
was a form that was an agreement that
was sent by the mountain district and i
agreed to it and sent it back
is that correct mr winter
um i believe this is an agreement under
for the
with the environmental services
so it hasn't been agreed by us and it's
not in our report at the moment
appendix e yeah
other yeah i i have to
disagree with that i'm not entirely sure
that has been agreed no i thought that
recall shirley
from the mountain council has
was dealing with this matter and i
actually emailed her
my agent my solicitors actually replied
back to her concerns
it takes
59
members
yeah that's the that's the environmental
health report but it's not in our modern
district so it's the environmental
health that's what that that's what they
were recommending however at the moment
your application states
that it would be until half past 12 at
night
okay so
um i think we need to look at what time
that that finishes
you also state
that um in terms of
uh the food and things like that so you
want a late night refreshment
every day again until
until
midnight
okay so again is that is that it that's
only on 10 occasions that you want that
okay
and what sort of occasions would those
be
okay so it would be
public holidays
and in terms of
the sale and supply of alcohol
so on sundays at the moment according to
a report that's that's tall
10 30
and monday to saturday again it's till
midnight is that correct
okay so
but that's not come through in your in
your application
okay
but it's not come through to our report
if you look at if you look at the app
your application
it still says those hours
so are you happy then in terms of those
particular situations that alcohol is
limited till 11 o'clock at night apart
from those 10 occasions that correct
okay
um
i still have a i still have
a a dilemma
in terms of the combination of high
quality designing
and this thing combination of
music and film so could you explain what
you're trying to create in terms of your
premises
so are you so my my concern is that is
is that you're saying one thing but then
you're going to be having sky sports and
and things like that and and crowds
where you're showing live tv
so with that so
okay so that doesn't fit with your high
quality dining experience
live sport
and a high quality dining
okay
so what what would you see the need to
show films
and have live tv
when would you want to do that
but people are in your restaurant at
that time
so why do you need to promote your
business within the restaurant
do you see my concern
so you what you are saying that you do
want to do things like play live sport
on television
you don't
okay
okay
okay
so your so your aim is is to is to have
a fine dining experience
so the aim is to have a high quality
fine dining experience that creates a
nice atmosphere
and won't be playing loud music
okay and what sort of levels of music do
you think would be acceptable in your
premises
we hire music from authorized companies
so the the level would be
given by them so that what the rules and
regulation of the country says the
volume would
contain the volume okay and would there
be any music played outside
i do have a garden okay but would any
music be played outside if you promote
permission if you give me the permission
then yes if no then
okay so do you intend to have speakers
outside
and it is
it's the same answer if you give it to
me i'll put speakers if you don't give
it to me there's no point give it
spending money putting speakers out
outside
it would be that would be no point doing
it
thank you very much okay
miss clark you did put your hand up was
there something you wanted did you can
you show your microphone please thank
you i i was just
referring to you you haven't realized
what what's written down because it is
up to
yeah so you know
you would feel that correct
and you you haven't realized what
yeah yes no no this being hard about it
but it's about what is most acceptable
here
so that was the first thing and what was
the other thing
i i did mention before that when i walk
past
the here to go go up here
like an
old lady i go up here
and if you haven't looked it up what you
saying about it being so clean it's not
and i've been going five five days
through just to find out every day what
it's like and i think the first thing
you could do when you go home
no it's not relevant to this hearing
have you got any questions for miss
bagan
yes please chairman um
sorry i've ended up a little more
confused than i was obviously a
discussion with councillor
are you planning as part of your your
ten events are there going to be
parties that you know people hire the
place for a whole party
yes there will be i'm hiring yes
and
you know well movie nights
no no
so this music
and in general terms not the 10 events
in general terms the music is background
music for diners that's right just like
lift music that's right
okay
right thank you
thank you chairman um
you mentioned about films would there be
sort of a birthday party or a wedding
where you would
play
evidence of that person in the past
like when he's two years old up to
his current age something like that in
that sort of context that's all i'm
asking
thank you very question um if you give
me the permission then will it be if not
then there won't be enough correct
um
are there any other questions council
siddal
mr winter so in terms of the exhibition
of film could you be clear in terms of
what that actually means
and what we would be granting there
um it
i don't think it refers to
your wedding type
film these would be
films that
are we know
true and well to be
a film um
like you would see at the cinema
that is the type of thing that would
need to be licensed
not the wedding type
films no not home
personal
don't need licenses for that it's it's
yeah yeah i bet is the question not as
simple as okay and and does that also
apply to live tv as well yes it does
okay thank you
so
so in terms of someone
in terms of someone putting up a
slideshow
of a wedding or or displaying something
private like that that doesn't need a
license but in terms of demonstrating
you're showing a film or live tv
it does require a license yes um
yes it does yes so
spaghetti back to you
what is the reason that you want
a license to show
films as a
business as a company we try to take the
most out of
the area make the most for the business
um
it is an offering if you give it to me i
would do it if it's not granted i won't
do it
but as a as a business we try to make
revenues as much as we can
as a business person that's all
okay
so in terms of the aims of your business
and what you want your business to be
what do you want your premises
to bring to molten
i've been open since 8th of september um
from then till today um i can say
we have bought
a business to modern
a revenue flowing
job creating
and giving a dining experience to every
single one that walks into the door and
we try to give that group good customer
service really that is our target good
food
um our dishes are more asian
subcontinent so it's not just
bangladeshi dish where i am from it's
indian pakistani
and
part of china
nepal
so it's more of all the countries in in
the asia subcontinent
um geographical ways and yeah
so is that it's so your focus is that
dining experience
rather than a party experience
is that correct
thank you ansel thompson
yeah thank you
um
yes so
was asking for a license to show movies
largely a question of let's take
everything while we're here and see what
we get
or do you have an actual plan thinking
well i'd like to do this and show no
time to die or you know what
whatever and have people come in and do
that just wondering what your approach
was
i can see why you would ask for
everything all in one hit not come back
um but i'd like to know what you what
you actually hope to do
um
i don't know if you have visited the
premises or visit to my site and it's
really nice really gorgeous i spent so
much money in it and the whole reason
why asking for the pro the filming is
for example if
a producer came and they wanted to use
one of my room just for photography or
advert
that was the reason ideally it's not
making it's not making a proper movie
out of chutney house
cannot can i come in i think
we might be on a different
thoughts here
the committee and what you've ticked is
for you to show films but what you're
actually talking about is someone making
films on your premises
we're not talking about making a cinema
in the premises
that's what you've applied for
you've applied to actually show
live live films
so so hence my concern is that you're
going to start showing
england football games and tele and
films so you you've applied for license
to show films and tv in your premises
not to have films made there that that
doesn't need a license
but you've applied for a a team tv and
film license mr winter said so
yeah mr winters members i just want to
clarify something when i firm it's a
license for a
a film it's an exhibition of a film
uh
if if
the applicant is going to be showing
sky sports or
tv channels that's a separate license
that's a different license for the
british broadcasting
association
um it's not
a license with the department so it
would be an exhibition
of a film
it's what you'd need a license for if
you're not intending to exhibit films
then
i might suggest there's not a
requirement for a license for that
but that's for you to decide
miss clark
i could
say to you just briefly
i think it's beautiful having the type
of food that you put into your office
everybody wants to go to that kind
don't change it to something that's not
nice please please keep it what you know
because
people come around from the area
pleasure to see you thank you miss clark
have we got any other questions from the
committee
not not for many years
so i just would like to
so would you like to make a remake
closing statement miss begum of what you
really want can you put your mic on
so we know yeah
so what we want to know is
what you actually intend to do
with that
premises
in one sentence make revenue
for the business yeah so looking at
licensing
and that's what we're here to consider
is your what you've applied for is your
alcohol license
your music license and your license to
show films can you sum up
if i was to grant all of them
i would have it
as a business any business would have it
but my number one priority with my
alcohol license
so that one
is more to see too
thank you before the 16th of october
thank you thank you
there's no possibility of granting that
license before the 16th of uh october is
there
it's a bit tight isn't it
um
we're on the 13th today that gives us
three days yeah don't think
get it i don't think it's relevant
really yeah we can only grant a license
when we can grant it but technically if
members are
agreed to the license or alter it or
mend it or refuse it
we will
the license will be granted as of
tomorrow okay that's all i want to know
really
depends on what we make sorry
is it relevant to
this licensing
we will have taken into consideration
when we go into private session and we
make our decisions we will take into
consideration i've looked very carefully
at detail
thank you chairman uh mr winter in terms
of
um
reasonable hours
what would you consider reasonable hours
for premises such as this
for sale of alcohol i would love to be
able to answer that but i have to remain
impartial the licensing department has
to remain impartial so
in terms of what you've heard and it's
uh in terms of those considerations
again i i have to remain in particular
okay it's really not for the licensed
department to okay
to say what is reasonable and what is
not that that really is down to to you
members to decide i'm sorry
i could care
thank you
the environmental health
issue would also come into that question
that you've just asked so
i will
ask a question of our legal
advice
um when we go in to deliberate this
licensing um
you have actually said we can grant it
in hull or we can
change conditions so we could if we
wanted to take out the films changed
the hours things like that
yeah that's correct julia thank you
if there's no other questions
uh in accordance with point 10 of the 81
memoir the meeting will now close
members will discuss the evidence and
representations made before reaching
their decision
all parties will be notified of the
decision within five working days of
this hearing so i'm sorry miss bacon but
members are reminded that the applicant
and or any person's making
representation in relation to this
matter may appeal the decision of the
council to the magistrate's call
members thank you for your contribution
this afternoon i draw the meeting to a
close sorry this morning yeah
i draw the meeting to close at 10 47
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to enter into any further
discussion on this forum and please
leave the meeting promptly if members
can stay
and the
legal representation if you would like
them to start